hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of the Walking Dead Season
nine episode 13 titled chokepoint
darrell plays - aw - with knives against
beta AKA Walking Dead Michael Myers kara
charmed some LARPers with a movie date
and Henry finally redeems herself with
some sweet moves I'm gonna break down
all the details that you might have
missed this episode and how The Walking
Dead pulled us all off and spoiler
warning in case you haven't seen the
episode yet and before I began thanks to
Philo for sponsoring this video
stick around to learn how you can start
watching episodes of The Walking Dead
within seconds and it's a special offer
the first 50 people to sign up using our
link will get their first month of philo
for free ok the episode begins by
picking up where the last episode ended
with an order of important sterile Conny
dog lydia and henry escaping the
Whisperer camp now if you listen closely
the last episodes final scene you might
have heard some of the whisperers
referring to the walkers as guardians
and we get confirmation of that here
when alphas second in command beta
surveys the damage one of their men is
bleeding out and they're exchanged here
is interesting weird the whispers are
praying folk religion isn't really part
of the whisperers culture in the comics
it's new to the show and I freaking love
it most survivors don't want to turn
into walkers when they die and plug in a
doomed loved one in the head before they
turn it's considered the honorable thing
to do but for the whispers it's the
opposite they embraced the whole walker
identity and they invite their eventual
transition into the next phase the
change they call it probably with a
capital C I would guess where they can
continue to be part of their family but
in a new role as a guardian a term that
for me echos the term guardian angel
so whispers don't see walkers as demons
like the rest of us do they see them as
angels which is really interesting this
season has leaned into the horror roots
of zombie folklore and this episode goes
even further in that whole cinematic
direction it's titled choke point from
Connie's proposed strategy to winnow
down the whisperers forces and take them
out from the higher ground choke point
is a military tactic in which a larger
armed force is forced through a narrow
essentially stripping away the larger
forces numeric advantage and giving the
upper hand to the smaller defensive
force so they could fit off the larger
force in that bottleneck famously this
tactic was used in the Battle of
Thermopylae by the spartan king leonidas
against the much larger persian army of
Xerxes the Spartans force the Persians
through a narrow pass allowing the
Spartans to hold the line shredded and
in slow motion here the whisperers are
the Persians their strength is in their
numbers with five to six of them able to
amplify their threat by towing dozens
more walkers along with them and Daryl
of course is the Leonidas choke point in
the whispers forcing them to leave their
guardians behind and ensure Leonidas
fashion kicking the dude down a hole
Daryl beta and Connie aren't the only
characters struggling within a choke
point this episode the kingdom is
preparing for the upcoming fair and we
get this shot of banners for each of the
four communities they're all different
with Shiva the tiger living on as a
symbol of the kingdom but notice how the
Sun shines over each community perhaps
as a way to suggest unity among these
four but Ezekiel and Carol are being
forced into a choke point by a new group
the Highwaymen whose sign they passed a
few episodes back the Highwaymen demand
a toll to use the roads at first they
speculate that these bandits could be
part of Jed's group the former saviors
but notice Carol's response wasn't
saviors don't write letters the camera
stays on her because of course she knows
this isn't Jed's group because in
episode 6 she torched them this is kind
of Carol's main move but now whether
it's guilt or wanting a non-violent path
to the fair being successful or
realizing that these guys aren't the
serious threats that are worthy of
burning live Carol proposes a peaceful
compromise the Highwaymen are led by
Ossie played by Angus Sampson you might
know him from the insidious movies and
Mad Max fury road his look actually
seems modeled on country singer Waylon
Jennings who was part of the Highwaymen
music group like Ezekiel this group is
all about theatricality as well they
dressed as Cowboys rather posts of war
Union soldiers who often appear in old
western folklore they actually might
have been sabor reenactors and now
they're continuing to LARP
which actually gives them a lot in
common with Ezekiel who embraces a
similar theatricality just more middle
times there was actually a really fun
detail in the scene that I'll talk about
in a second first thanks again to Philo
who sponsored this video and thanks to
their support we're gonna be able to
break down the remaining three episodes
of The Walking Dead Season 9 guys I am
officially a chord cutter now I use only
streaming services to get all my content
and Philo has been perfect for me
it has over 50 channels including all
the stuff I watched on AMC Comedy
Central and it's really the easiest way
to watch The Walking Dead I can start
watching within seconds and there's
unlimited recording so I can save as
many shows as I want because I watch the
last stuff I like to dabble Philo is
available on Apple TV Roku Android iOS
fired TV it has been simple and
affordable for me only $20 a month for
all this content I've been saving like
100 bucks a month on my cable bill peace
for me it has been the best solution to
stay cord free and commitment free and
has a special offer just for you guys
the first 50 new rock stars fans to sign
up using our link will get their first
month of Philo for free get on this just
visit WWF Aiello TV slash new rock stars
that's ph IL o TV slash new rock stars
okay back to the scene with the
highwayman if you listen closely when
Jerry whispers in ezekiel's ear
it sounds like Jerry named his sword
Excalibur the legendary sword of King
Arthur and Jerry would very much like
his sword back yeah Jerry you make sure
to get that scabbard to the way these
highwayman chivalrously ride up on their
horses and they tip their hats it's a
whole over the top but only just so
Carolyn knows that the prospect of
seeing a movie is something that these
nerds will probably really want enough
to agree to keep the road safe and free
Terra's group from that choke point
Carol also notes that their letter was
grammatically correct grammatically
correct death threat yo suggesting that
these people must be civilized the
Highwaymen name might also be a literary
reference to the famous narrative poem
the highwayman by Alfred Noyes about a
highway bandit and his lover they both
died tragically it's known for its
suspense and repetition a really good
poem to read aloud I wouldn't be
surprised if any of these LARPers had
writing writing writing in their heads
as they swooped in to save Tara another
interesting detail I found about the
highwayman is the way they present
themselves to Ezekiel scattered among
mannequins in this sense they mirror the
whisperers hiding among
heard amplifying their numbers and
sowing confusion over which figures are
actually human this old killer hiding
among mannequins trope is something that
we've seen before in films and this kind
of creepy suspense imagery is all over
this episode the daryl versus beta
storyline is a classic slasher film in
the style of John Carpenter's Halloween
at the beginning Lydia debates Darrell
over whether they should trap themselves
at the top floor of a building which is
a nod to the classic rule in slasher
films never run upstairs and beta is a
masked killer in the vein of Michael
Myers he's huge he's terrifying
he coolly demands through walls and
seemingly doesn't feel pain and he's
pretty clever like notice now once he
realizes Darrell has a crossbow he later
used as a table as a shield when he
barges through the door and I just love
the choice to set the sequence within a
grid of hanging tarps perhaps as an
homage to the way John carpenter made
flapping sheets terrifying and Halloween
Connie and Daryl defeat these whispers
by recognizing these tropes like despite
her deafness Connie can see the glare
from the whisperers flipped knife a
knife glare being a common cinematic
trope in horror films and she knows to
duck and Daryl beats betta by being a
better slasher killer hiding and
Connie's secret stash compartment
sneaking out and springing out on beta
from behind pushing him down an elevator
shaft unknowingly repeating best big
move in season 5 now those other details
aren't intentional nods to Halloween
this final shot of the episode
definitely is an overhead shot of the
masked killer seemingly dead from the
fall but no twist he's actually alive
and now he wants revenge because
sometimes choke points can squeeze
someone just a little too tight there's
no question for you guys what movie do
you think it's gonna be screen at the
kingdoms Night of the Living Dead to
Metta Mad Max - post apocalyptic comment
below with your thoughts follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at a vas and
subscribe to new rockstars on YouTube
and follow our podcasts wherever you get
your podcasts thanks for watching bye